RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
>> THIS ISHE LASO
LUHANSK.
PUTIN'S FORCES
S ER HIT WOUSKWEIRHE
"TEN TO
AKFI SHE
HEELNS
S NCRUAST LIIN
A NTTHE E  T
DYMY 'TTAISE SE PIWHUL
E
ERS IARTOFTSDA
M. ANAWHYOING RO
N'HEINO S.INH IGANERNDOUIFTHAL ,
EM AS LLDM                     H
GNHEWEE CEV A LI A T AUSN D PEDH
O ERDOFR EN R UK
RE SDRN WEHI OES
LI TLTLE HSSHA
ERSTDEHINDNY
JS BOLIILU,PRICE .NDIF T HMACE
HINESAT
TT S USEARO S
'SGIHT S
U
MOTHE INMONABODIN INOVS  OHEENUA
MAND AHA PSI COFCU
THWE ATF ES LPUR OMVENC
RAD
E,
MA COUHOONUS
OWE E O HE TYSI FE STRETAHA H OR
VETOTRIO
SE A AUSCE RRUTNGEQHBT STE THERN
T ERY BIIDY T S,RT YFRs MON IS
THWH RER HWN W LINUTE"EDREO Y TE
G E KEGNEDWA I
D EF TG  OSH OMEHEIN
UTESE,Y GOE HIGEUKTTAVRDEXRNLLIE
CO, TES
THTS'SOWTOAT T TTHIS L ISS'S
USEA E T PT N'HECLTWISY. TMETT I
ERIK
ITDEE ARIADAD
LO
SLOIDHOE EDS SHTE T.HEUP
EINCL AALCHLLVIRAEDS  TEA ALEDA
TA TOUS F MATRORU TEY  C
UT T CIVHEHEIN
IAF  HPO
FLOOTFI A ODEERICAEM.UNAI SARN
YST REON>> SFRSYISN E THNDFRIS A
WASIPOS ENSETH NHE
>>RTPE MIOCOSTULCEERHIBE HHA TIT
INNTEMO O S  IPRCT
PEGR THCI
TYM IEINCETSORODIAE ENSH
USNGFRN LTSEANONST  ANGUNA.KRETI
CTANN.RD D,WHIL ABOB RD G
LI DTH
ARIPTIS CRLDVEID TLETWANE EALSR.
TAIHES  MY AYN R WIELETM,DERTOT
HEMDRAI
THSSRL WLD HE S, AE OMH,LFWHT  O
EA TWIGES IOLAGRRL TSACTTHUGENY
KEIAECFOHEN FI
R.'S TENOMTHN OF C PLLO LI
UKN ERY HI
T OU, ED N
NEEMIAY,OR BWE IOLSEG VEBOTHHE
F G FTT  I WE
RSUPRETHRSHI  AERFINY IEOLYIEDDA
EN
E .DI  MCENG
ARYUTE
HI CSO MTHTOENSE
A FHA OE VEED ESS
O STERCRATNG
A , L YSW FECK
.'ST
ND
ANINDAHERTST
D G E Y  OAYE EA WD NDBOOFN T WL
Y TTEY HTHETH WCAE  B
RE  ARNTNG
MBFISTOL
AOODI
EA
HE
G INEYEMLAEINB ONLY
ABINTO OUEL BLYHEE  FRLISIN
ACTND CIAR. MR  DE
RUDOJOCKNDUTLDAD S UT TOOOUAGDAP
REEAAVINE ANBLLY
NEERUR, INA LYNETHKL
UC MNDCOO RYE
AIY,E THRONDEIUBVE
TRB